suite avec drieu godefridi les docteur
en philosophie auteur de rouleaux de
comment l'amérique invente le siat et et
olivier py ton avocat aux etats unis et
auteur de kamala harris la pionnière de
l'amérique
bonsoir merci à vous d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors le sommet
du quad qui se déroule ce soir en direct
puisque ce n'est plus un sommet virtuel
comme c'était le cas au mois de mars
dernier ça veut dire que joe biden il ne
s'arrête pas après la sphère des
sous-marins ses ambitions dans la région
à un dock pacifique elles sont plus
larges en puisqu'avec ce sommet du quad
votre avis là-dessus
quatre idées
et ses délires que ce à quoi on assiste
seidel effectué à sion
l'un des rares bon d'accord aujourd'hui
entre les publicains et les démocrates
c'est à dire le fait de considérer la
chine comme étant le nouvel ennemi est
donc tout ce vaste mouvement ac il se
fit agit de l'australie où des réunions
de landes japon et céda s'explique l'un
des rares éléments transcende les
désaccords entre des notables et des
nôtres à territoire c'est à dire
effectivement l'organisation la la mise
en la mise en ordre pour confronter
effectivement les velléités hégémoniques
et j'ai pas seulement dans la région
hégémonique au sens stricte à deux
jeunes chinois vous êtes d'accord olive
et python
oui absolument c'est tout à fait juste à
dire que l'obsession chinoise des états
unis est encore patente avec cette
réunion du quad il quand même amusant
pile de se rendre compte si on est un
tout petit peu taquin
que
tous les propos qui sont tenus par les
américains ont tendance à
systématiquement linverse des actes
qu'ils qui met en place le meilleur
exemple c'est que la sphère des sous
marins avec australie avait eu comme
l'une des conséquences du rapprochement
entre la france et la double un des
bodys le premier ministre me dit avait
rappelé l'importance de la coopération
stratégique et militaire avec la france
et sept cette réunion quoi baril sont
opportunément vous permettre aux
américains d'une certaine manière de
boucler la boucle et de renforcer avec
les indiens comme ils le font avec les
japonais et avec les australiens et avec
les britanniques et avec l'ensemble
monde anglo saxon cette espèce de bois
de voitures du cercle qui consiste en
réalité à se focaliser sur la chine est
bas dans l'histoire la france pour
l'instant elle s'est nourrie juste deux
mots et on attend de voir les les
mesures concrètes de ce qui a été
apparemment décidé entre joe biden et
emmanuel macron mais incontestablement
il ya un vrai décalage entre les mots
extrêmement chaleureux et les actes qui
ne suivent pas drieu godefridi dans la
lutte d'influencé
face à la chine on a un sentiment
finalement quand les etats unis se
transformant en un rouleau compresseur
qui est a finalement écrasé l'europe la
france c'est c'est ce qui est en train
de se passer en ce moment
cyril et le le le l'univers mental dans
et les américains se
se déplace pour le moment c'est de
considérer la puise deux hommes comme
dans la chine comme étant l'équivalent
de l'invasion de la tchécoslovaquie par
l'allemagne dans les années à tant d
années 30 le la proie suivante je dis
lol c'est taiwan et ce serait
l'équivalent de la région la pologne
c'est à dire la guerre parce que c'est
clairement il faut pas se payer de mots
le le schéma adopté bien évolué
maintenance et préparer la guerre alors
vous parlez de rouleau compresseur vous
avez raison parce que tient alors
c'était intéressant de voir l'espèce de
continuité parfaite entre la politique
de baden et celle de trump qui s'est
d'ailleurs personnellement par surpris
de la halle à faire des sous marins avec
l'australie soit qu'une initiative de
monsieur byden casser les morts je pense
que cette négociation dax de
l'administration de notre oeil alors oui
une forme de rouleau compresseur mais
qui n'est finalement pas une réponse à
un pool pas aux velléités hégémoniques
mais revendiquée de la chine ce ne sont
pas les américains qui fantasme de les
velléités gb dit que la chine c'est la
chine qui revendique véritablement cela
et on a une sorte de mécanique ou
d'engrenages qu'il pourrait passer pour
un final certains égards est
effectivement en train de se mettre en
place son chine jours mais les
américains n'en pas n'importe pas seul
la responsabilité
et quant au rôle de la france puisque
nos modes de vie et sur ce point bon il
est clair que on vous prend évidemment
le délégation de la france comprend la
déception de la france en dit que dd
greer on peut les opposer les retards
mais il ya les grilles de la france
l'ena la révolte que je dirais de la
diplomatie française de sénateurs passe
pour un détail de l'histoire parce que
les choses s'accélèrent et donc fallait
justement olivier python la perception
outre atlantique
du poids de l'europe et de la france
aujourd'hui
écoutez elle est assez simple le poids
est devenu beaucoup moins important
qu'il ne l'était à l'époque de la guerre
froide avec l'urss pour des raisons
d'abord purement géographie j'ai une
stratégie qu'à l'époque de l'urss
l'europe représentait le champ de
bataille potentiel en tout cas l'un des
champs-de-bataille potentiel ça n'est
plus du tout le cas aujourd'hui il ya un
basculement qui a d'ailleurs débuté
avant même donald trump qui a débuté
sous barack obama comme chacun sait vers
la zone pacifique et vers la zone indo
pacifique et ce qui a été dit est tout à
fait juste dire qu'il ya une
responsabilité partagée il n'est pas
question de de dire que les américains
dans cette histoire serait forcément
coupable et que les chinois serait d'une
certaine manière les victimes agressées
ça n'est pas ça et on sait très bien que
la montée en puissance de la chine
nécessité de la part des américains une
réponse forte le problème c'est que la
france dans cette histoire et c'est
peut-être le plus humiliant c'est que la
france s'est retrouvée
balayé en tant que dommage collatéral
c'est à dire qu'elle se trouvait dans
cette volonté américaine de créer une
sorte de blocus comme on l'a comme
truman avait fait à l'époque du
containment avec l'urss donc l'idée
cette idée d'encercler donc tour et la
chine et de l'empêcher de pouvoir
développer ces ses atouts et on
particulier ses atouts militaire et pour
cela il fallait un accord avec
l'australie la france était au milieu
donc il pourrait donc le plus humiliant
dans cette affaire c'est peut-être un
petit peu le dommage collatéral ceci
étant points du français
ce qui est important de voir c'est que
ou bien la france et c'est visiblement
la direction qu'elle est en train de
prendre avec une sorte de 2,2 calme
d'accalmie entre les gouvernements
français et gouvernants américains soit
la france décide de
s'arrimer aux américains et de guider 1
2 les britanniques ce qu'elle est en
train de faire à l'heure actuelle on
continue à faire lanterner les
britanniques et les australiens ou bien
la deuxième possibilité c'est de
profiter de cet incident pour essayer de
tenir ou d'avoir une position plus
indépendante ça n'a pas été la direction
qui a été prise par emmanuel macron
emmanuel macron pense qu'il peut gagner
sur deux tableaux le premier tableau
c'est d'une certaine manière créer de
fait une solidarité européenne qui
pourrait déboucher sur un partenariat
de défense européenne et le deuxième
aspect c'est qu'au bout du compte il y
aurait une sorte de pendant entre un
impôt européen et un pôle américain au
sein de l'otan ce sont de vrais
comment dirais-je sont de vrais calcule
pas du tout évident qu'on y arriver en
tout cas c'est la direction que l'on
prend à drieu d'être aidé
jean yves le drian ministre à des
affaires étrangères cet entretien avec
son homologue américain anthony blinken
il y à une rencontre entre emmanuel
macron et joe biden prévu fin octobre
et puis boris johnson qui a tendu une
main
à emmanuel macron en évoquant une
coopération finalement c'est quoi tout
cela ce sont des lots de consolation
pour la france c'est exactement ce que
vous dites ce sont deux lots de
consolation et dans le calme du vol à la
police rue d'alix est d'autant plus
facile que le nôtre fillon je dirais
intime de botanique dans cet acteur est
de taille parce que voilà c'est une
chose c'est à cette nouvelle alliance
c'est d'abord le retour de la grande
digue de sacs seul et c'est une alliance
n'aurait pas été possible pour le
royaume uni sans le reste de l'europe
s'ils rumigny était encore dans l'union
européenne donc là effectivement ils
font ce qu'ils avaient dit et ce que
john seul disait à l'époque militaire
pour le break 6 à savoir que lohan dit
allez retrouver sans le demi sa capacité
à peu avec ses habits un peu partout
dans le monde donc oui maintenant la
france par recevoir un lot de
consolation dont je crains fort qu'elle
devra ce secteur pour une raison très
simple hausse et elle n'a pas les moyens
de faire autre chose
olivier pétant fois la réaction
française
si vous voulez la décision a été prise
de ne pas rompre les ponts avec
l'alliance atlantique y compris en
décidant par exemple un retrait du
commandement intégré la décision a été
prise de ne rien changer et d'essayer de
2 de ceux de se nourrir de mots de se
payer de mots à une un approfondissement
des relations entre la france et les
etats unis c'est très bien on va voir si
ça marche il ya peu de chances que ça
marche en tout cas il ya peu de chances
que ça marche sur le long terme tout
simplement parce qu'encore une fois
l'objectif des américains n'est pas de
câliner la france elle n'est même pas de
satisfaire l'europe le sujet il n'est
pas là le sujet il n'est plus là le
sujet il est de trouver le moyen le plus
efficace de contrecarrer l'ambition
chinoise et dans cette histoire la
france joue un rôle extrêmement nina et
si je devais vraiment être un petit peu
plus
intrusif je dirais que la france donne
aussi des bâtons pour se faire battre
parce que à partir du moment où la
présence française dans l'inde au
pacifique dépend de notre présence en
particulier en nouvelle calédonie en
polynésie française encore faut-il
envoyer à nos voisins et en particulier
nos loisirs australiens et néo zélandais
le signal que l'on souhaite à tout le
moins garder la nouvelle calédonie au
sein de la république pour que l'on
puisse poser je veux dire
géographiquement dans la région or ce
que l'on envoie comme message des
tractor message qu'on envoie c'est que
finalement l'indépendance de la nouvelle
calédonie serait parfaitement acceptée
par le gouvernement français dans ces
conditions les acteurs du pacifique et
en particulier l'australie ont
légitimement le droit de se poser la
question de ce que représentera lé
influence française et la présence
française dans le pacifique dans 10 ans
ou dans quinze ans et c'est une vraie
question donc on doit aussi se regarder
une même français pour savoir quel est
le rôle que l'on de jouer dans le
pacifique et est ce qu'on s'en donne
finalement les moyens à partir de ce
moment là il ya une question qui se pose
pour la nouvelle calédonie
incontestablement ans est d'acord rien
qu'à traîner sur la nouvelle canne et
d'asnières
je suis entièrement d'accord avec les
avec son élite avec llanelli ce qui
vient d'être fait c'est à dire que le
l'ancrage territorial à la france dans
cette région de l'est et cette
crédibilité évidemment on n'a pas pesé
lourd lorsqu'il s'est agi pour
l'australie de pouvoir cinq mille
sources il reste de très loin à la
première guerre mondiale face à la
menace chinoise estimant qu'avec vous
parlez de 10 ans 15 ans la menace
chinoise tvq à bon nombre de
responsables salle est aujourd'hui comme
étant littéralement imminent et cela
d'autant plus et c'est un élément pour
ma propre et par les endroits de la
nouvelle zélande vient tout récemment de
s'acoquiner est véritablement non pas
avec les américains mais avec le régime
chinois
en quittant le système deschamps vrais
enseignements en mieux saxons
complaire d'allemand la chine est donc
l'australie vit un sentiment d'imminence
dans la menace chinoise va choquer le
cercle ancrage territorial de la france
est un élément qui était pertinent mais
qui est de peu de poids je dirais j'y
tiens merci beaucoup à vous drieu
godefridi docteur en philosophie et
auteur de l'autre comment l'amérique
invente le siac merci également à vous
olivier py ton avocat
aux etats unis et auteur de kamala
harris la pionnière de l'amérique merci
à vous